my guest today is dr cal newport he has
never
ever been on social media before
seemed like they were engineered to
really distract you because even early
on this was clear that social media made
money off your attention
there has to be other reasons why you
kept saying no no no to social media
no one really had a good reason why i
should be signing up for it that
definitely caught my attention
wouldn't you see tv as a distraction
similar to what social media would be
i was really starting to get concerned
when i saw people constantly pulling
their attention down to that phone
and yet it also seemed to be capturing
so much of people's time and attention
that for someone who made a living with
my brain i was very very wary about this
there is a benefit to social media even
for a guy like you
what you think is social media when i'm
using the term i'm thinking about
attention economy platforms where your
data time and attention is the primary
product to sell
there's a part of me that fully agrees
with
you the way i think about things through
my digital minimalism
perspective is there's not something i
really value in life for which any of
those platforms is a really big win
[Music]
my guest today is dr cal newport who got
his phd from mit i whispered to him
earlier i said i learned how to spell
mit my 30. so again phd
from mit's written seven books two of
which are
new york times best sellers he has tens
of millions of views
on social media on youtube there's only
one kicker
he has never ever been on social media
before we're gonna find out today that
in the next 60 minutes can we convince
this man
to open up a facebook and a twitter
profile
no one's been successful yet let's see
if we can pull it off or not with that
being said
cal thank you so much for being a guest
on valuetainment
yeah thanks for having me on let's uh
yeah let's see if you can get me over to
the dark side
i highly doubt that's gonna happen you
seem pretty convinced where you're at
and i think it's even deeper rooted in
some of the
set of values and principles and on the
way you live but i think the question
today is really going to be
how many people you can convert to come
to your dark side to get
off of uh maybe not dark side to be
enlightenment i think it's more
you're probably more free than those
that are on social media having to check
70 apps every single day so why don't we
go all the way back so
uh you know one of the biggest
challenges for all of us
is that hey i'm on facebook you got to
get on what's facebook dude just get on
okay i'll get on facebook hey i'm on
myspace you got to get on what's my
speed dude it's sick you got to
go again hey have you looked at twitter
you gotta get how did you say no to all
of those temptations every time people
said you got to get on a social media
platform
you know facebook was the first and the
way i
remember it it was the spring of 2004
right i was a college senior in the
spring of 2004. back then facebook was
going
university to the university it was
still sort of in a beta stage so it came
to
it came to where i was i was at
dartmouth college i remember my friends
and my girlfriend everyone was sort of
into it right like ah it's the
facebook.com it's sort of like
the literal facebooks we have but but
virtual and there was like an
arbitrary reason why i didn't sign up
and my memory of the arbitrary reason
was
i don't like listing favorites
it's a weird tic i have if you tell me
what's your favorite book
what's your favorite movie for whatever
reason i i i just can't do that i have
an aversion to it and early facebook
this is what the profiles were centered
on as you would list your favorite
quotes you would list your favorite
movies so for an arbitrary reason
it's like oh i don't want to do that wow
that
accident though it gave me this
interesting almost anthropological
separation you know like i was margaret
mead
studying studying uh tribes on an island
or something so i was separated from
social media as it began to spread
and after a while just observing it from
the outside to me became way more
interesting than actually being in it so
it was an accident that got me started
down this path
so okay fine so you decide not to get on
your favorite and that was kind of like
your or your thing
but i mean from 04 to 2021 there's been
17 years for 7 billion
something people in the world to
convince you to get on social media and
you
still haven't done it so what there has
to be other reasons why you kept saying
no no no to social media what was that
what was that reason
well so after i graduated college in
i went to mit and i was not only the
computer science department but i was in
the theory group
within the computer science department
so this is the group in which you have
all the theoretical computer scientists
so we
literally stare at white boards and try
to solve math proofs
in this really unusual sort of
idiosyncratic type of professional
environment
focus was everything your ability to to
maintain
focus was really highly prized people
did not spend much time
engaging with the outside world it
wasn't reading a lot of news it was
i'm locked in trying to solve proof so i
went from college into this environment
where what people really cared about is
how hard can you focus and when i was in
that setting
to expose myself to tools that seemed
like they are engineered to really
distract you because even early on this
was clear that social media made money
off your attention
it's being engineered to get as much
attention as possible we all looked at
it with great suspicion so i didn't sign
up for arbitrary reasons and then once i
was in this unusual professional
environment
it became really suspicious of why would
i bring one of these tools into my life
it seems like it's going to get in the
way of what i'm doing it would be like a
professional athlete looking at
cigarettes and saying you know
i don't really want to bring these into
my life because i make a living off my
lung capacity
do you have a tv do you have tv in your
house yeah we have
we have tvs my wife and i are cinephiles
we like to watch movies so we have that
so wouldn't you see tv as a distraction
and as cigarettes uh similar to what
social media would be
well so the issue i had with social
media was twofold
one no one really had a good reason
why i should be signing up for it that
definitely caught my attention it was
like because it's here
and i'm like okay but what do you do on
the facebook.com like well you know you
see
like who your roommates boyfriends are
dating or something but that's not
interesting
why should i sign up for this no one was
really giving me a good reason
whereas if you look at a tv and say
there's a great movie
and you can watch it on this screen i'll
say well that's a pretty compelling
reason
and two it became clear pretty early on
that these platforms had a lot of energy
being invested into making them as
sticky as an experience as possible
they had the ability to manipulate your
attention to manipulate your emotional
centers to manipulate your social
centers they get you to look at these
things
much longer than you knew was useful or
much longer than you knew was healthy in
a way that you couldn't really replicate
with something that was as asymmetric
and static as television so i was really
starting to get
concerned when i saw people with these
networks following them everywhere they
went
and was constantly pulling their
attention down to that phone right so
there seemed to be something new going
on so we had these platforms where no
one could really explain why i needed to
be on it
and yet it also seemed to be capturing
so much of people's time and attention
that for someone who made a living with
my brain i was very very wary about this
just out of curiosity cal who were you
in high school if i was in high school
with you 14 years old 15 years old who
was cal
um in high school i was
i ran track uh i
was a smart kid but but maybe not
considered like a
one of the brains i had a
long-standing group of friends i'd had
since elementary school i mean i was
relatively popular went to the parties
uh by my senior year i was a little bit
unusual by my senior year i was running
my own tech company a sort of a web
development consulting firm with a
friend of mine that was doing pretty
well
and i ran out of computer science
classes to take so i would drive to
nearby
princeton university to take their
computer science classes so there are
some things that started to set me apart
as i got a little
bit uh older in my high school
experience but i was a relatively
sort of semi-popular normal kid i would
say
as far as being raised by your family
what set of values and principles were
you raised on
well i mean one thing my family always
valued was
the brain as an asset and intellectual
life as one
to aspire to you know my
my dad had a doctor and i've been a
professor for a while my grandfather his
dad had a doctor and was a professor for
a while
uh there was something we used to hear
stories my dad would tell stories of
like richard feynman you know the famous
quantum physicist
well we would hear about john von
neumann so we
we really respected the life of the mind
and using your brain to create things
that was new and valuable that was
definitely in the air when i was growing
up
which is why i ended up going to mit why
i ended up going to the theory group
is i love that idea of the john nash
beautiful mind
drawing on the window solving things
with just your brain that was definitely
something that had always attracted me
that's so ins that's so interesting now
how about values wise were you a
church corn family were you a religious
family did you guys
follow a certain code or you know
commandment were there certain set of
values that the family followed
uh growing up we were presbyterian okay
my dad had been raised southern baptist
so
for example uh there's no cursing right
that's something i really noticed is
like
in our family there was no cursing i
still rarely curse to this day because i
just didn't grow up for example
uh around it my parents didn't drink
alcohol that was another thing i think
that came from the the southern baptist
upbringing so i i had both those threads
certainly all around me from a value
perspective
got it so so and did that continue on
into your teens and young adult and as
an adult yourself like have you
continued a lot of those traditions
yourself uh well well certainly not the
no drinking
okay yeah i i will enjoy i'll enjoy a
good lager
uh now and then but yeah i would say
definitely have a strong
foundation of values like i'm very
interested in religion and theology i'm
very interested in moral philosophy
i take very seriously having a code and
a set of values i actually what i do
and and i recommend this a lot to my
readers is i have a lit
here's my values and you should have
them it should be written down right
and you should review it and i often
tell my listeners and my readers like
review these every week and i'll
actually create i call it a value plan
every week
little notes hey here's what i'm working
on this week right you know i think i'm
kind of falling short on this or here's
something i might want to punch up
and i write it as part of my weekly plan
okay here's the i call the vp the value
plan
so i see it as something that i'm
constantly working on because it's
really core i think the resilience more
than anything else
life's going to knock you down a bunch
that's the that's the ground that you're
going to fall on so you want to keep
that ground pretty firm
and this is all going to a place here
the only reason i'm asking this because
i'm going to place with this i'm not
just asking it for entertainment
purposes although it's very
enlightening to see how you were raised
so recap
pop's doctor grandpa phd
and that lineage keep goes up in your
family the life of a mind you guys
respected the mind
no cursing certain set of values review
your value on a weekly basis were there
any other set of values or
like if i'm my dad would say never be
afraid of the truth okay
and he would say rather than learning
how to fight with your
uh uh you know you know with your hands
why don't you learn how to fight with
your mind and your mouth right learn
yeah go do your circuit
what were some of the things you were
taught in your family growing up
well you know another value i think was
that was unusual to our family
was independent thinking and to be
concerned
about ideology right so so one of the
unusual things i
grew up in is my dad's job most of the
time i was
growing up he was the editor-in-chief of
the gallup poll right the public opinion
pollsters
which meant that publicly he had to be
very non-partisan because they did all
the
election polling and approval polling
he lived that in and outside of the
house so in our house there was no
notion of partisanship there's no notion
of
wow we're for this party and so now what
we're going to do around the parties
talk about how the other party is bad
everything came from a place of detached
uh observation well
the people who support this kind of like
they're kind of thinking about this and
the people over here
well they think about this it was all
sort of detached and so i think it was
really
it was pretty rare especially today but
to this day it is very difficult i'm
very wary and maybe this is also because
i don't use twitter which might
push me into more of tribal thinking but
i'm very wary of tribal thinking
i'm very wary of ideological thinking
where you
you fix your team and then work
backwards from
let's defend our team and not give too
much ground to the other team that is
very
foreign to me but i think that attitude
is actually that i have is pretty
foreign to most people and it's because
of that unusual
upbringing where there was no
partisanship right i mean you have to
realize
the way you're raised is one in a
million okay the way you race is not
very common so
i'm asking this question because uh your
parents
must have done a very good job raising
you guys to the point where don't make a
decision just to please everybody else
and
you know don't follow the crowd if
somebody's doing cocaine or pot or
ecstasy or whatever you don't need to do
just because they're doing it question
it
make think for yourself a lot of those
set of values you know respecting the
brain but alcohol came to you later on
so if your parents weren't for you to
drink in alcohol
it's not like you're 100 loyalty is not
to do what your parents tell you to do
because you do drink
alcohol so then why social media like
and then you're saying i didn't see any
value on being on social media but i
know a lot of people that are on social
media
that use it as a method where they're on
instagram they only follow
28 people and only 28 people follow them
they don't get any advertising on
instagram they see pictures of what the
28 people that they love the most
are doing and they get to post pictures
and videos of the people
the 20 people that they want to see what
they're doing so there is a benefit to
social media even for a guy like you
why why would you think a hundred
percent of what social media offers
isn't good because you can turn off the
triggers and all the advertising and the
way that
facebook instagram twitter tries to
trigger your mind you can control that
but why still say no to social media on
the positive side that it offers to you
well i'd flip that around and say why
spend all that time like
what what is the big win i'm going to
you know spend all this time trying to
set up triggers and reconfigure
uh unless i have a compelling reason oh
this solves a big problem for me
watching the movie doesn't solve a
problem for you though well i enjoy the
i enjoy the format i enjoy the medium
you know and i i enjoy
i enjoy movies right uh you know i don't
to me i see it like some people like
bike riding right and
so i won't say uh uh i get that you
really enjoy bike riding uh it's very
enjoyable but i don't happen to
like bike writing that's not one of the
things i do but i did actually write a
whole book about how you should make
these decisions so so back in 2019
i wrote a book called digital minimalism
where this was the question
how do you figure out the use of
technology in your personal life and the
answer to that book was not
here's the good things and here's the
bad things no one should use social
media everyone should use
watch movies or whatever the philosophy
that came out of that book
was essentially what's important here is
working backwards from
what you value what you care about your
vision of what you want your life to be
like once you really set what's
important to you in your life then you
can work backwards and say what's the
best way to use technology to amplify
these things i care about
and i had 1600 people go through this
experiment where they
got rid of all the technology all the
optional technology in their personal
life
spent the month really reflecting what
do i care about what i want my life to
be like and then rebuilding their
digital life from scratch
about 50 of them had social media as
part of that answer
so to me what's important is not what
tech is good and what tech is bad it is
are you deploying tech intentionally oh
here's something i care about you know
i'm an artist and there's these other
artists who put their works in progress
on instagram
and seeing other artists in my fields
works in progress is crucial to my
creative process so yes i use instagram
for this purpose
that's fantastic right that's deploying
technology
intentionally to support things you
really care about and so that philosophy
which i call digital minimalism is what
i really been pushing now for me
when i go through the things that are
important to me and i want to spend time
on and i use tech in a lot of
intentional ways
social media just hasn't made the cut
right there's there's no particular
thing in my
particular life that this is very
important to me where social media is
a really good way of using tech to
benefit it so it's not in my life
but for other people they answer that
question differently i care about how
people
ask it not necessarily the answers they
end up with
so can you tell me what you think is
social media so maybe
say this company that company this
company social media what is social
media to you
you know typically when i'm using the
term i'm thinking about attention
economy platforms
where your data time and attention is
the primary product the primary thing
they're extracting to sell
and i make a distinction between social
media and the social internet i'm a big
early booster of the internet and the
social internet i think using the
internet for
expression and connection is very
important so it's really that
attention manipulation aspect it's a
large platform closed garden
trying to extract monetize your data
your attention so that would be
uh you know it's hard to keep up with
but the classics would be facebook it'd
be twitter it would be instagram
it would be tick-tock on the other hand
things like there's there's really
hazy dividing lines instant messenger
services probably not
whatsapp right whatsapp is sort of
they're trying to be more like a
a social network but it's it's in its
own sort of in-between space for
example uh group text messages is not
obviously things like being on a podcast
or something is not right
youtube i don't know how to think about
it you know right because youtube is a
very complicated thing it is the
best video is incredibly important it's
a great platform for
it but they have this recommendation
engine which is trying to grab your
attention but it
so like i think youtube is in a weird
space right so it's not super clear-cut
some things are i think twitter's pretty
clear-cut
i think facebook's pretty clear-cut i
don't know how to think about youtube
i don't know how to think about whatsapp
you know i don't have to think about
clubhouse like what is clubhouse i don't
really know
i'm doing a clubhouse you know shortly
with a
a tech reporter from the new york times
to see what it is because i don't even
know what that is so it's not an easy
question to answer
you got it so do you watch youtube i
mean not a lot
but i'm fascinated by youtube because i
think democratizing video is incredibly
important and it
seems to be really the only game in town
right if i'm understanding obviously
you you're a master of the medium there
really isn't a co is this true there's
not really a comparable platform that
makes it
that's so good at uh hosting video and
displaying video and you can play in all
these different
tablets and tvs and phones and
um so yeah i use i use youtube often
like a library when i'm trying to look
something up or want to say okay
yeah exactly or there's someone i'm
interested in i want to see them
interviewed
i you know so i'm very interested in
youtube i don't i don't know quite how
to think about it but i think it's
something very important happening there
well you you seem very sincere and
almost like an
innocent way of thinking and a very
clear set of
uh uh standards on what you uh
classify as social media or now some
would say youtube is a social media
company
second largest you know on traffic etc
etc and you're right there's not
necessarily comparable to them
vimeo some of these other companies
facebook may say yes we are
direct competitor of youtube maybe on
short clips facebook's not big on long
form like you're not going to see too
many three hour podcast
on facebook instagram may say we also
get on the short
videos one minute two minute five
minutes ten minutes
not necessarily our type of thing so so
then that
uh uh goes back to twitter facebook
instagram
being once that you have a challenge
with and it's is it
mainly because they get to dictate
what you watch next and they're able to
trigger
and kind of manipulate the whole thing
to say hey cal you like this let me feed
you some more of this hey like
the whole social dilemma documentary i'm
assuming that's the part that you
uh uh don't see any value in using those
social media platforms is that a good
uh way of putting it well i mean i want
it i want to put it so starkly so so
again the way i think about things
through
my digital minimalism perspective is
there's not something i really value in
life for which any of those platforms
is a really big win the thing i'm very
wary of is what
in another book i wrote i call the any
benefit mindset i think especially with
tech it's very dangerous to approach
tech from the ask the mindset of
could there be some value here if so why
don't i try it
in some settings that's okay it's nice
to explore but because of the things
you're talking about that's a dangerous
decision
in the world of the social media
networks because innocently let me just
like do some instagram
might end up being seven hours a day it
might end up being
i am on this way more than i think it's
useful way more than i think is healthy
so
you have to be a little bit more wary
with these platforms because they are
very good at grabbing your attention
once they're there so i keep going back
to look if there's a big win i'll use it
but
it could be interesting you could find
some new readers there might be
something interesting
that's not going to be compelling enough
for me especially when there's so many
of these attention traps that have been
engineered into the services so i'm very
wary
cal do any of your family members uh uh
use
social media probably yeah i'm not sure
which platforms but
i mean i think i'm the only person
between the age of 20 and 45
left in this country uh who doesn't use
social media so
i think i can confidently i think i'm it
you know i mean i
i think when they have board meetings at
facebook and they have audience
acquisition charts there's only one
thing left on it which is a picture of
me
all right we're almost done we're almost
done so what do you what do you keep
pictures where do you keep pictures of
family like albums
uh on my phone so which which by the way
is i think a probably a strategic
mistake that was made by the major
platforms
is starting around 2012 to 2015 they
said we're going to shift away
from the original premise which is this
is a place to connect with people you
know and we're going to switch instead
towards a news feed model we are going
to use
algorithmic information to get you a
steady stream of things that's going to
be
engaging to you and a lot of people just
migrated things like sharing photos with
their family they're like well fine i'm
not gonna do this on facebook i'm gonna
do it on a group
text message chain i think ultimately
that's probably gonna be an issue for
these platforms because if they lose
their
network effect advantage if it doesn't
matter to me whether or not my cousin is
on facebook because i can just send him
a picture of my kids
on imessage now facebook's
advantage why i have to use that
platform gets way reduced once it
becomes just a source of entertainment
yeah it's a stream of stuff that
algorithms are selecting it's engaging
it's competing with every other fort's
uh form of entertainment out there
much more competitive landscape cal what
do you do for fun outside of watch tv
in movies well i mean i only have so
much time i have three young kids
three young kids and a couple jobs so i
don't have a ton
i would say of downtime i do as you
might imagine read quite a bit since
that
is my life as a writer
you know depends on consuming and
producing the written word so i do read
quite a bit
but i'm not someone who has quite a bit
of downtime do you document a lot of
what your kids do with videos and save
them
no not really it doesn't have a value
for you
yeah we don't i mean we we uh we'll
share
pictures and videos in the moment with
family members i think that would be
more
uh the more way we do it um but we're
not of the old the old school of the
camcorder
and building up the building up the
library the library of tapes
when when you said in 04 when the
facebook came out and was kind of making
the rounds through school to see who's
dating who
and he said my girlfriend and i is your
is that girlfriend of yours now your
wife
yes so so you guys been together for
over 17 years
yeah we actually we just had our uh 20 a
year
yeah or 20 year because we started
dating before that so we just hit our we
hit our 20-year anniversary
congratulations last week yeah and is
her personality like yours
what's her personality like you know she
has her own thing she's not weird like
me
yeah you know thank god she has her own
personality
um uh no it's different she has her own
thing going on
and but both of you guys are on the same
page of not using social media
she does whatever she does i mean i'm
not going to tell her or anyone what
tech they showed or shouldn't use
the main things i write about is what is
my suggestion for how you make those
decisions that's the main thing i care
about
again i don't have a list of good and
bad tech does she use social
i don't know i think she might have a
facebook account i'm not quite sure i
mean again we're both pretty busy with
the kids and everyone you're married to
your wife
you would know if she's on facebook no i
don't know if she uses facebook or not i
think she has an account but
i don't know i i don't think if she does
i don't think she spends much time on it
got it so i i ask because
uh you know look
okay so one part on what you're saying
um i took
a 90-day break from youtube four years
ago
let me tell you it felt like a million i
mean i can't even say a million bucks
because a million bucks doesn't feel
that big it felt like
unlimited supply of freedom for 90 days
okay
when i said i'm not going to post i
don't want to create content i don't
want to do interviews i don't want to do
more i don't want to do this get that
camera away from me
it felt amazing no joke it felt amazing
so
sometimes when i watch these guys like a
johnny carson or
a jay leno or a jimmy fallon or jimmy
kimmel or
david letterman i'm like oh my gosh what
a life to go 20 30 years and you got to
be on that camera non-stop and
fake it even though you just got into a
bad fight with your wife and you're
going through a divorce or your kid just
got caught smoking weed or
your mom just passed away or you doubt
you do wow
what a amount of pressure to have to
fake and
act for that long of a time so there's a
part of what you're saying
i get when facebook first came out i
didn't even want to get online because
i'm the private guy
i'm the guy that you never knew who i
dated i was like you know pat that's
always got to grow but we just don't
know who are you with today who are you
dude i don't really want to advertise
who i'm dating i'm good with who i'm at
and we're having a good time together
but if you see me out there
i'll introduce her to you but it's not
something i want to advertise so there's
a part of me
that fully agrees with you
and can see that direction there's
another part of me that's
sees it as another form of entertainment
where strategically you can control
on how to use it you know like back in
the days a lot of people were worried
about
radio or or elvis song hey you know
oh my gosh you're moving your hips too
much and all girls are thinking about
sex and this is not good our daughters
are going to start having sex with
hundreds of men and this is not
the direction we're going you know what
about this hip-hop music look at this
why is
you know tupac and biggie and all these
guys why are they cursing so much and
why are they saying this kind of this is
not good and
you know it allows us to make the choice
to do what we want to do
the way you've taken it you've taken it
to a whole
different level now maybe this is a
question that i'd be curious to know
what you what you would say to this
do you think you will ever get on social
media like do you think there'll ever
come a moment where you'll say
i think it makes sense for me to open up
an account now or do you think you'll
never do it
well i mean first thing i'm going to
push back a little bit on the analogy
right because
i mean let's imagine rock and roll music
is is sweeping through the country in
the 50s and 60s
and there's someone who says look i'm a
i'm a classical guy i don't really like
rock and roll whatever you know i i i'm
into the piano i think these chord
progressions are too simplistic or
whatever it is right
that would be fine and we wouldn't go
and say that person like no you have to
listen to rock and roll music
you're not allowed to dislike rock and
roll music when the person is like look
i'm just into music appreciation i write
books about music appreciation
that i think would be the right analogy
here right so uh
for me to say i don't see a lot of value
in social media for what i'm doing right
now
is not an indictment on the existence of
the technology right
uh just like i was saying with the bike
riding analogy before
um i'm happy if someone's really friends
who are really in the bike ride i think
it's a cool sport
but if they really started bothering you
like how why don't you bike ride don't
you see that this is going to make you
healthy and has disadvantages or
whatever it's like look
just because i'm not doing it i'm not
trying to put down that you do
but i'm not out there saying uh we
should burn
bikes oh you've never seen that no i
don't i don't think that's i don't think
that's the position you hold
yeah yeah but just just uh to set that
platform so so would i end up yeah
because i'm a digital minimalist i mean
again the way i come at things is
uh do less do more do better right so
i'm
very intentional very picky but i mean
think about the tech i do use i i like
the strategic deployment of the tech
when i see a big win
so like i have a blog which i've had
since 2007.
that's been a big win for me you know i
have this this audience i've developed
my thinking and i've had an audience for
years now who's been a part of my been
part of my interactions
one of the reasons why i didn't need for
example uh
to let's say go on facebook just to go
back to that
another aspect here is that because i
was an early adopter of tech
i sort of already had my own platform
whereas if i didn't
right if i wasn't so tech savvy it would
obviously have been much easier maybe to
post on facebook or twitter because one
of their advantages back then
in that early web 2.0 days was were
easier just technically speaking
it's a pain to set up a wordpress and
get a server or whatever but i kind of
already had that going
i've embraced podcasting right it's
another tech that
i've embraced i thought and it's been
good you know i've been doing it since
uh
last summer but we're coming in on two
million downloads it's been a great way
to to
interact with us interact with fans so
you know
absolutely i think any technology that
comes along
could come through that process of
thinking i do and so you know what
this is going to be a big win for this
thing i really care about
the existing platforms just haven't
passed that threshold
uh for me yet and it because again i'm
very focused on the things i do they
haven't been a big win i care a lot
about distraction so for me
and my minimalist calculus they haven't
crossed that threshold
the only thing i would say which is just
to give credit to what you're saying
before is like
there i i it is right i do have a sort
of underlying antipathy here and that
does come from the social dilemma style
attention manipulation
i'm also as an early internet booster i
do not like this idea of taking
something as democratic as the internet
and then trying to build your own
private versions that exist in server
farms that you own so i have a
philosophical sort of techno utopian
disagreement with that so so you are
actually right that beyond just
my minimalist analysis of what i use and
don't use there is a little bit of
underlying antipathy and i don't want to
pretend like there's not
and those are the grounds on probably on
which that antipathy is formed is
i'm an early internet guy i don't like
this idea of trying to build your own
private internet
and i don't like some of the attention
manipulation things that some of these
companies do so that is there
and that is a general thing i'm
concerned about um but more generally
i've got i this is the way i think about
tech and so i podcast i blog i could
certainly see
something that we would collect you know
categorize as a social media platform
entering my life and
the key to me is the intention yeah
um you're born on the same day as my
best friend is born
okay you guys are identical so weird how
how wiring
i mean i don't even know how much
there's you know whether you're a gemini
or
cancer and i think you're maybe a cancer
on the day you're on the cusp of it
right and right in the middle of it
you and him are born on the same exact
day uh are you a crypto guy
do you do you believe in blockchain are
you someone that says i think crypto is
going to go places
oh yeah there's a can of worms
i i i i know a lot about crypto i taught
i taught a doctoral seminar last year on
some of the the mathematics behind a lot
of the
the blockchain technologies i'm not an
expert so i want to
all right so i'll be careful i'm not a
real expert on the specific
products and usage of this underlying
technology right so i'm not deep in the
weeds of exactly what's happening with
non-fungible tokens and how ethereum
smart contract language you know
is going to be different than what you
can do on a more limited blockchain
style language like i'm not really
a an applied expert i do have a
my general skepticism here's my here's
my i'll put it it's just
as long as we're being controversial on
everything that people like my general
skepticism
about uh the crypto future is that i
think what we're learning from
these various blockchains is that it is
immensely useful
to have some sort of shared ledger that
we trust
that can have especially interactive
contract style entries that we can't go
back and change it right
i think the real promoters of the
technology though what i'm thinking is
they're over
they're overestimating the degree to
which people are distrustful though and
i just imagine a future in which okay
let's say a big company let's say google
this is going to give crypto people
heartburn
says yeah we have a ledger and no it's
not it's not a crypto ledger we're not
doing proof of work like
you know we're we're transparent about
it it would be very hard for us to kind
of fake and go back and do
and change the ledger and we'd probably
be caught if we did and also why would
we
and uh but just use this when you want
your
shared public ledger to build these apps
i just have the sense that for 95
of the applications that are being
developed right now people say yeah i
trust them enough
and their service is it's an easier
ledger to work with it's faster we don't
have to do proof of work we don't have
to
you know it gets rid of some of the
weird hard edges so
um what i think is going to happen is
you have there's this deep philosophical
political core that helped
push this technology and i think there's
gonna be a wide audience that doesn't
care so much about the deep political
philosophical
core and it's like oh this is just
really useful having a universal shared
ledger that doesn't change that you can
build many different applications on top
of so
there's there's my prediction is that uh
the
trust aspect is going to be uh
depreciated
as we get more used to the value of
having these universal shared
what else ledgers i what else can i
destroy what else can i uh
destroy right now that's gonna get me
yelled at by internet people
who would have taken the angle of going
to the ledger as far as crypto goes
whether you trust the ledger or not what
a lens you got like
again one of your favorite games to play
uh based on what you said is your
favorites right you love playing
favorites like what's your favorite
okay is your favorite movie
like the beautiful mind are you like one
of those types of guys like have you
watched a beautiful mind or no
yeah what do you think about that movie
i look i like the book
even better i look i grew up on those
books like those guys the
the women that had these brilliant minds
and
i don't have that but um man i aspire to
it i don't know why okay
i don't have that what do you mean you
don't have that i mean listen
john nash got a nobel for for figuring
out the group dynamics like i don't know
you know
look i'll tell you what knocked that out
of me was going to mit
i thought i was a smart guy and then i
went to this theory group and
man was i disabused of that notion
because seriously are you being serious
are you being sincere about this i'm
being sincere there so
one floor of this building at mit yeah
there were three macarthur genius grant
winners we're talking about genius
they're literally macarthur jr genius
grant winners
and two turing award winners i could see
all those offices from my office one of
the first professors i met when i got
there
was he became a professor at mit at 19.
19. he became a professor had a
macarthur at 19 as well
uh he was tenured at 21 like he couldn't
go with his grad students to get drinks
because he wasn't old enough
i mean it's crazy right so it's all
relative i guess
he couldn't go to the park he was 19
years old
he's 19. wow uh
well you know for the rest of us
geniuses we look at you
and and you you qualify as the way you
see the world
as a so how about investment wise what
do you think about mutual fund what do
you think about stocks what do you think
about real estate real estate as a
source of an investment
well like i'm one of these boggle head
efficient market
hypothesis type nerds right that which
is partially borne out of i just don't
have enough
uh time and attention to think much more
for it so i'm a big vanguard guy
i'm a big passive guy uh i'm i'm not a
big
i'm really worried about the the kruger
dunning effect when it comes to
investments right the most dangerous
people when it comes to investments are
people that are pretty smart
because they're smart enough to believe
you know i feel i'm smarter than most
people so especially in tech we have
this problem smarter than most people so
i can
believe the hypothesis that i can figure
out you know
secrets in the market and stocks to
invest in and make money on it because
i'm smarter than other people
but not smart enough to realize that
actually the the people at these hedge
funds that at these banks that are
already working in the market spend
their entire life studying this right
and and uh it's an efficient market and
there's not really you're it's being
you're flipping coins and you're getting
uh
you're getting too excited about
gambler's ruin going in your direction
for a while right so
uh i mean i find like smart tech people
get in the most trouble with investments
because they believe in themselves
enough to believe in the idea that like
if i study stuff i can figure out stuff
the market hasn't realized yet i can i
can figure out advantages in the pricing
so i'm all about look man let's get this
in a let's get this in a vanguard fund
let's get this
low expense ratio let it ride
uh i always say i'd rather spend more
time trying to think how to make more
money than spend that time trying to get
a little bit more money out of what i
already have
but then again i'm infamous for being
bad at money so uh
don't take any of my advice around money
as as something that you should follow
because it's not my strong suit
let's talk about one of your books that
you wrote deep work okay
uh rules for focus success in a
distracted world phenomenal subtitle
right
uh how do we stay focused
you know and succeed in a ridiculously
distracted world today
well i think 80 of the value of that
book is the title
i'm a big believer in you know sometimes
just having the right terminology
opens up all the decisions you need to
make right and when i was writing that
book i thought the big thing
that was an issue is that we didn't
divide different types of efforts into
different types of efforts which is like
work was work
and i'm either busy or not like how much
am i doing and like the main thing i was
trying to argue there is let's break up
work in the two different types of
categories right there's deep work where
you're doing one thing for a while
without distraction and you're really
thinking hard
and there's everything else the emails
the zoom the
the jumping back and forth on you know
slack or what have you and it's not that
the everything else is not important is
what keeps the lights on you have to
submit your timesheet if you're going to
get paid
but it's not what moves the needle right
it's not where you create the new thing
it's not how you get promoted it's not
how your company grows and so i said
once we realized there's two different
things now you can ask the question well
how much of the
the deep work stuff am i doing and once
you knew how to measure like what it was
you were measuring i just think a lot of
people realized the answer was zero
and once you realize the answer was zero
the alarm bells go off and then you
start to make changes and in some sense
how you make the changes i think is less
important than you realize that it's a
problem
and so just that term that that is a
particular type of effort
just putting that semantic distinction
into the universe was probably 80
of the value of that book let me let me
ask you you know in in
this whole thing with deep work uh and
straight a method you know
i think that's another book that i don't
know if that's a book you wrote i think
that's a book that you're right studying
is a skill
if you get good at skill you can learn
how to get better so
what is your method of researching i
think the
the one skill that we all have to get
better at today is researching it's
quite frankly i don't think it's
something that we give enough credit to
and we don't talk about enough you don't
see a lot of guys online talking about
i'm the research expert here's how to go
do research effectively but i think
like almost everybody i know that it's
super super successful
in the world of business and investment
they're one of the best at their method
of researching a topic and studying a
topic
what is your philosophy and approach to
research and by the way even if you guys
were taught at mit and you were around
all these other macarthur geniuses
that you learned from them what did you
learn as far as how to become a better
researcher
well i think we've lost familiarity with
thinking as an activity
you know it used to be something that
there was there's very few people for
which thinking was relevant because
there's very few
what we would call today knowledge jobs
right like almost every job you would
have involved
moving you know a hoe through soil right
uh or or
butchering a carcass or whatever and the
only people doing knowledge jobs were
theologians and philosophers and there's
a few scientists and writers around but
they used to think a lot about
thinking what it feels like it's hard
right
the way we talk about doing exercise
like we're pretty used to like weights
is hard and here's what it feels like
and
you get the burn and then there's a
runner's high and all this type of stuff
it all exists for thinking
it's uh you're applying cognitive energy
to take information and move it into
internally in your mind into a more
useful structure and it's difficult and
there's strain
but there's a euphoria when you make
when it clicks because your mind likes
when things fit together
and we used to think a lot about
thinking
now that it's relevant to a lot of
people we haven't thought as much about
it and people just aren't that
comfortable with
what it feels like to think hard it
feels hard and then it feels good and
you practice it and you get better at it
and it's a core activity
that's the way i approach research right
whether i'm talking about in computer
science or whether i'm talking about
in you know uh my book or article
writing i see it
almost like an athlete thinks about
training i think a lot about thinking
i'm gonna i'm gonna
try to understand this hard idea you
know yesterday i spent
the morning yesterday trying to
understand it's about a half page of
mathematics in a paper
like if i need to understand what
they're doing if i could understand what
they're doing i might be able to use
that for this related problem i'm
working on and it was just a couple
hours of sitting at my whiteboard here
in my my offices
and it's okay here's the math on the
board why are they doing that
come back to it okay think about it come
back to it think about it come back to
it that's sort of just
comfort with cognitive strain where
you're putting your energy towards
things that are a little bit beyond
what's easy for you to understand
exerting cognitive energy to try to move
that information into a more useful
structure to build understanding
that is the the axiomatic action
of valuable knowledge production it's
something i think a lot about and i
protected a lot about and i'm
comfortable with and used to
i think a lot of people aren't and it's
something we should probably discuss
more
interesting crazy question for you um
if plato aristotle socrates i don't know
friedrich nietzsche you take a marcus
aurelius
seneca if all these guys were around
today in their social media
which one of them wouldn't be on social
media
all right that's a good question um i
don't know if aurelius would be on
social media i think socrates for sure
would
right because he would he would say this
is great
what is twitter if not a giant
dialectical experience and
he's trying to find or or he would be
terrified by it because
actually okay um let me let me reverse
that socrates would have been an
early user of twitter let's say and then
would have become
a sharp anti-twitter critic
wow this is this is what i'm going to
say because because here's the thing
right like
the the the socratic method like at the
core
of his approach to knowledge right he
had this approach to knowledge in which
you uh clash ideas back and forth and he
did it through dialogue and in this
dialectical collision you got deeper
roots of understanding and this is what
all his dialogues were like and one of
my critiques of twitter
has been that it's it's actually moved
us away from that
and towards a more like tribal notion of
knowledge where it's much more about my
team thinks this your team thinks that
uh so he would call it um sophism back
then right
and all that matters is that you don't
give ground to the other team like you
want to find an angle to dunk
on the other team and but whatever you
do make sure you don't give ground
that was really sophism which socrates
was against and he was much more for
this the socratic approach
where you're like okay let me get the
best possible argument against what i
believe
then collide that that how i believe and
in there i learn even more so i think
socrates would would love the idea of a
global discussion because we're all
going to get smarter
and then he would see the way it
tribalized and say
digital sophism this is making things
worse so that's where i'll put down my
chip socrates would be one of the
earliest users and then one of the most
he would be the tristan harris of
the philosophers or something he'd be
really anti-anti-twitter after he'd been
there for a while
but aurelius would have never gotten on
it i guess
i mean is it because he could care less
for recognition he's like i don't need
the recognition i don't need to get the
exposure
is that why the reason yeah and he was
so intentional right and he was so
intentional about like
this value-driven activity in his life
um
but then again you know if you're an
emperor or what have you maybe it's
useful because you can reach your
it's these are weird these are weird mix
if we brought him you know if he had
twitter back into that time maybe it'd
be useful for talking to your subjects
or something but he feels like someone
that would be
say like i don't know this is not deep
enough right let's go
let's go write poetry i feel like if
twitter was around back in the days he
wouldn't be
wearing the clothes he wears it'd be
it'd be different clothes he would wear
well if instagram was around for sure
yeah photos of that
oh my gosh so okay so books wise
how many hours do you read and how many
total books do you think you've read in
your lifetime i'm curious
yeah i mean so the reason why it's a
little hard for me to answer is it
depends
you know whether i'm doing research or
not like when i'm working on a book i
might
be reading a book a day but like what
reading means here is is
a little bit tenuous when you're talking
about research because you could be
shooting through some things quickly and
diving into other places
i would say i typically am reading about
five or six books at a time
and i switch back and forth between them
throughout the day over the weeks over
the months and some things
i keep coming back to again and again
over a long period of time some books i
just read in a single day
so i probably spend about an hour a day
reading you usually have five or six
things arena at a time
um so you know i've probably read a
decent amount i mean i'm not
my friend ryan holiday kind of pushes us
to an extreme right where he
he he reads like 20 books a month that
he didn't give his big summaries of i
don't always hit that
but sometimes i do sometimes you hit 20
books a month
if i'm researching something for sure
right like if i'm writing an article for
the new yorker for example
those are long form articles that are
often like highly citational based
it's not uncommon that there might be
six or seven books i need to go through
just as a foundation for that particular
article
if i'm writing a book chapter to quickly
go through six or seven books for that
chapter is not
not unusual right so this stuff could
really add up if you're especially if
you're doing research
wow very impressive to see that you
wrote a book
having to do with passion you have
strong opinions about passion
because we're living in a time right now
where you know you hear a lot of
motivational speakers saying go chase
your passion you know
uh you drop everything it doesn't matter
if you're broke and you lose everything
as long as you are pursuing your passion
that's the way to go are they right yeah
so
we're going through the whole list of
things that people are going to dislike
me for so we've done social media i
don't like social media we've done
cryptocurrency right i've been mean
about cryptocurrency so yeah let's go on
to follow your passion
we're next i'm going to talk about how
soccer is dumb and that'll be it and
then we'll
have hit every topic that uh yeah i
wrote a book in 2012 that argued follow
your passion as bad advice
um which was so here
i mean okay so here's the the background
behind that
right the background behind that point
was
when people say follow your passion like
people who
are living really interesting lives or
whatever what they often mean
is follow the goal of ending up
passionate about your work
right life is short it's worth having
your work be a real source of
satisfaction and which i think is really
important but then it gets simplified to
the shorthand to follow your passion and
my argument in the book is
if you study how people actually end up
passionate about their work it's
usually not what that simple advice says
right it's usually not
i'm pre-wired to do this once i match
that to my work i'm passionate
it's usually more complicated path with
discovery and growth along the way and
so my argument is if we make the advice
too simple
we actually hold people back from the
destination that we all agree on it's
you cultivate passion for your work and
it can be a complicated rich and
rewarding
process and journey let's not simplify
it down to
you are wired to be a social media brand
manager for a major sports franchise and
until you get that job you're going to
be miserable and then when you get that
job
you'll love it because you're brave
enough to follow your passion it's a
more complicated story we should tell
the more complicated story
last but not least you got a book coming
out called world without
email can you tell us about your book
world without email
yeah i mean my argument in that book is
the way we're working today is
is almost absurd we spend almost all of
our time in many office jobs
checking communication channels
constantly inbox slack
teams whatever it is that you use and
some of the data that i cite is once
every six minutes or more
we check in on one of these channels and
i argue if we look at the neuroscience
and psychology
you can't do anything useful with your
brain in such an environment because the
context shift
that you generate when you turn your
attention to an inbox and try to turn it
back to what you're working on is
incredibly disastrous to your ability to
concentrate
and so it's a terrible way to try to
actually do knowledge work and people
have to try to do their work in the
early morning or in the evening and none
of it makes sense and so
this book argues that that way of
working was pretty arbitrary
once email spread and it spread for very
good reasons it was replacing fax
machines and voicemails once email
spread
in its wake people started working in
this way we'll just figure everything
out with back and forth messages real
quick
it's killing our ability to actually
work and it's making us miserable
the future of the world of work is going
to say we're going to have other ways of
collaborating that's not just
back and forth unscheduled messages and
we're all going to be much happier and
get a lot more done it's going to be
more of a pain to figure out these new
you know there'll be more hard edges
more systems more rules
sure but what we're doing is so terrible
that it's going to make everyone better
off that's the world without email
i pitch not that the tool is going to go
away i don't want to fax anyone but i'm
not going to be using these
hundreds of back and forth messages all
day as the main way that i collaborate
with people
listen if i ever see you becoming
a massive twitter facebook instagram
star or tick tock like if one of these
as i wake up
and i'm reading an article on new york
times
tick tock superstar cal newport
video goes viral 93 million views in two
days
quoting how socrates would use twitter
today
he is with us right now and you got like
a purple color hair with like three
earrings and nose ring and tattoos
and you see us singing a sea shanty
about how socrates would not use twitter
that would be
wow i can't see that i can i can see you
being a massive tick-tock star um
where you know who knows that dwayne
johnson calls you saying we want to we
want to have you in the next movie so
your followers can watch it
i'm telling you if that ever happens uh
i will be calling for a part two
interview to say what why did you why
don't you tell us this that you you
got the star in you you're hiding you're
not telling the rest of the world first
of all
you're you're you're genius yourself
second of all you have the right values
and principles and you're a social media
superstar you kept us all this
away from us so i'm looking forward to
that follow-up call
to see you being on instagram and
twitter and i
follow and click like when i see that
picture
i don't know isn't that one of the signs
of the apocalypse it's it's it's the
there's the horseman there's cal newport
on tick tock like there's a couple signs
that when you see him you know
the end is nigh yeah i've really enjoyed
talking to you listen
you know there's a part of me that
agrees uh uh and
would thinks many many many people would
benefit from life if they actually
subscribe to your way of thinking there
are a lot of people that would benefit
from it
i think a part of it also has to do with
the business and the industry and career
you choose to be a part of
certain industries and careers like you
know i was talking to a guy the other
day who
came out and said you know remember the
guy dan price who came out years ago
saying i'm paying all my employees
seventy thousand dollars and i'm taking
my income from one point one million
dollar
income to only 70k and all of a sudden
his executives left and
but he was running a merchant account
company everybody made 70 grand here and
it was like the story got 500 million
was most viewed story ever on nbc and i
interviewed him two weeks ago
and he and i were speaking and i said
you know
dan you can do that in your industry
you can't apply that method in every
industry so maybe
your approach works for you or ryan
holiday ryan's on social not as much
as the rest of the guys he is on social
he writes great books anything he comes
out with
i'm the first to pick it up and have
everybody in our company read it
uh i think obstacle is the way our ego
is the enemy's excellent book we've read
a mult multiple times
i kind of see you guys as a similar
place that you think as stoics and
i apply a lot of those thinking this way
so i'm not
far off from where you're at but there's
a benefit to it on the business and to
do
which helps the business i'm currently a
part of if i
ever become a 4.7 gpa mit graduate phd
that i can go write books
where i read six books to write one
article for new yorker i'm going to
contact you just once you know this
yeah but i'll be on tick tock i'll be on
tick tock so i won't get your call see
that that's
we're just gonna let's just swap this
around
well buddy appreciate you for your time
gang we're gonna put the link below for
world without email for you to go order
it
and uh i was gonna say if you want to
reach out to him go send him a message
on twitter but you cannot find this guy
he's hiding he's the hide and go seek
champion
of the world today cal newport cal thank
you for your time
well thank you i enjoyed it take care
buddy bye-bye can you see yourself never
been on social media meaning like no
facebook no twitter no youtube
nothing nothing socially no instagram
and would that benefit you and your life
and would allow you to make better
decisions and spend more time reading
and getting better it's an interesting
way of thinking i definitely think
we need more folks from his end to
balance out those who are far
right on one end with social media
because
if there is a philosophy today that
would benefit many people that changed
my life
i'm a big marcus aurelius guy i've read
the book meditations multiple times and
the philosophy of stoicism
would benefit so many different people
in business if you've never looked into
it i did a video one time called
stoicism
the ancient philosophy for entrepreneurs
if you've never seen
that before and you enjoyed today's
topic i have a feeling you can enjoy the
city
video that i did i think last year two
years ago click over to watch the video
i want to hear your thoughts comment
below take care everybody bye